[Musik]
red zum achten mal findet heuer mit
perry lee wall street die inoffizielle
weltmeisterschaft der gewinnerstadt von
15 bis 16
märz treten gebirgsjäger gruppen aus
zehn nationen in den tuxer alpen in
tirol gegeneinander an
der wettkampf fordert sportliche
höchstleistungen und gleichzeitig lösung
militärischer einsatz aufgaben unter den
teilnehmern befinden sich mannschaften
aus russland großbritannien italien
bulgarien und rumänien zu die
deutschland schweiz und österreich
seit 2004 wird dieser dieburgs wettkampf
war durchgeführt
heutzutage wird dieser wettbewerb auch
angeboten im rahmen der mountain
training initiative der europäischen
initiative für die gebirgsbildung und
gebiet der wettkampf startet zwar bei
schönem wetter unterwegs müssen sich die
teilnehmer ab auf jegliche
witterungsbedingungen gefasst machen
in zwei tagen in den voller
kampfausrüstung müssen die
unterschiedlichen gefecht aufgaben im
vorgebirge bewältigt werden
während des fordernden wettkampf liegen
die soldaten einer strecke von insgesamt
40 kilometer und 4000 höhenmeter zurück
durchhaltevermögen und teamfähigkeit
sind voraussetzung um am ende auch
erfolgreich durch ziel zu laufen müssen
die teilnehmer außerdem hohes
fahrerisches können und gute
führungsqualitäten mitbringen
an den stationen diese verschiedener
bewerbe zu meistern
dazu gehört zum beispiel die füße von
verschütteten lawinenopfern
[Musik]
nach der abfahrt zum lager errichten die
teilnehmer ihre diva kälte und sammle
kräfte für den nächsten tag
nach einer kurzen nacht auf 2500
höhenmeter müssen die fünf am zweiten
gerät index immer wieder startklar sein
es ist schon mal gut und motiviert
eine der größten herausforderungen am
zweiten tag ist das klettern über die
schwierigen face gerade im alpinen
gelände aber auch das abseilen und das
scharfschießen hochgebirge führt die
teilnehmer an ihre physischen grenzen
[Musik]
leben
die letzte hürde stellt die steine
abfahrt mit dem bewerb verletzten trent
da das warme wetter und die einsetzende
erschöpfung sorgen für schwierige
bedingungen da hinten
lauf zum beispiel als härtester kampf
der welt zu ende
das führt damit die schweizer ganzen
aufgaben 12 yoy habe sie kurz die
pannenshow starken rentenzahlung
hinterhof in der puffer gehabt aber das
wird uns noch kindern hört man natürlich
immer den atem im nacken
die herausforderung war sicher den
werkzeug schlimmer wer der hitze defekte
stück auch ziemlich er hat sich etwas
gezwungen sah die opfer da war doch
geringer herr schick war weiß ich nicht
der ideale schnee warum ist dann aber
kommen die weltmeister der seine
heimliche kurzhaar kampflos werden und
dadurch zum die größten und
sommersprossen wir uns eigentlich so
verglich das team aus nordhalben locker
ausklingen lassen
preisverleihungen wahrscheinlich zuerst
heimrecht getauscht
das gremium vormittag verließen von
möglichen lieberoser weg sind
[Musik]
eine siegerehrung werden die drei besten
teams mit trophäen ausgezeichnet
der krieg bleibt geht heuer an der
österreichische team ist egal bataillons
24 auf dem erst tirol deutschland
sichert sich den zweiten platz und die
schweiz sowie den beitritt 2007
entwürfen aber niemand gibt ja nur aus
jeder teilnehmer erhält nach bewältigung
des wettkampfs auszeichnung in silber
wer bereits zum dritten mal dabei ist
nimmt sogar das goldene abzeichen mit
nach hause wollten mussten gleichzeitig
als ansporn in zwei jahren wieder zu
kommen
absolut fair und ohne großes lob an die
veranstalter hier geben
[Musik]